et c'est encore l'été ou quoi là
attendez je vérifie par ma fenêtre
invisible oui c'est encore l'été le
soleil est toujours là et il invite
toujours aux apéros à rallonge
ap ap ap ap ap qu'il soit encore là là
mais parfois à l'apéro il peut y avoir
des convives n'étaient pas vraiment
l'épée c'est la fête y compris pour les
deux
est ce qu'elles sont vraiment dangereux
comment les éviter
que faire si on est piqué la réponse à
toutes ces questions avec des thés ses
partenaires de votre épée
aujourd'hui c'est le tour d'une bestiole
qui a un nom de super héros sauf qu'en
fait pas du tout c'est le frelon
asiatique
à quoi ça ressemble un frelon asiatique
écoutez c'est très facile de reconnaître
un frelon asiatique grâce à un moyen
mnémotechnique extrêmement précieux un
frelon asiatique
ça ressemble énormément à offrir long
trop long classique frelon européen
sauf que un frelon asiatique c'est un
peu plus petit mais c'est vrai que c'est
pas facile à repérer comme ça mais aussi
qu'un frelon asiatique
c'est plus foncez vous voyez le frelon
asiatique il a une livre et j'ai un mot
vous pouvez employer pour vous la péter
ça veut dire l'aspect visuel d'un animal
il a une livre est donc beaucoup plus
foncée un presque tout noir sauf là
jusqu'au bout de l'abdomen et là au
niveau de la face ou c'est jaune orange
et il a aussi le bout des pattes jaunes
alors qu'un frelon européen ça ressemble
à une guêpe mais qui aura un prix
plusieurs fois du fromage
voilà donc un pronom asiatique ça
ressemble à ça et c'est une bestiole qui
est pas si facile à repérer parce que 1
ne fait pas beaucoup de bruit quand tu
es vols et 2
elle a tendance à planquer son nid dans
des trucs abandonnés ou dans des arbres
genre at 15 not do étoiles problème
c'est un horticulteur qui a remarqué en
premier la présence de frelons
asiatiques en 2004 chez lui dans le lot
et garonne
selon toute vraisemblance il ferait
arriver là dans des poteries qui l'avait
fait importer de films jusque là pas de
souci alors c'est quoi le problème
bah le problème c'est pas tellement pour
les humains en fait enfin si ce n'est
pas directement le frelon asiatique
c'est surtout une menace pour la
biodiversité parce qu'ils s'attaquent
aux abeilles
ils les bouffe est pire dans les régions
où il y en a beaucoup les gens ont
tendance à mettre très tôt dans l'année
des pièges pour tuer les frelons
asiatiques sauf que ça marche pas très
bien sur eux par contre ça tue des
pollinisateurs et d'autres insectes donc
ça aggrave encore le problème
au final tout ça ça nuit aux
pollinisateurs donc aux végétaux aux
insectes donc aux oiseaux qui démangent
par exemple et du coup ça nuit à tout
l'écosystème qui est déjà beauf en forme
donc à moyen terme c'est mauvais aussi
pour les humains alors je sais vous
voulez savoir aussi ce que ça donne à
court terme
donc oui un frelon asiatique
ça pique sa piqûre elle peut être plus
douloureuse que celle d'une diète mais
pas forcément que celle d'une abeille
parce que son dard ne se décroche pas
quand hippiques par contre du coup il
peut piquer plusieurs fois d'affilée ça
c'est pas ouf
et comme son bar et épais il peut même
piqué à travers les vêtements mais en
soi sa piqûre n est pas plus dangereuse
que celle d'un autre bestiaux c'est
comme pour toutes les bêtes qui pique
c'est dangereux si on est allergique ou
si on est piqué plusieurs fois d'un coup
et ça se faire piquer plusieurs fois
d'un coup c'est quelque chose qui peut
arriver parce que je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez mais il a tendance à
planter son nid donc on peut tomber
dessus par hasard et sans généraliser
mais comment on fait pour l'éviter
le prolo asiatique il n'a pas de vision
nocturne donc il ne peut pas voler la
nuit
du coup dormait la journée et ne sortait
que la nuit
voilà bonnes vacances romain était là
ouais ok tu dois bien le cochonnet sens
fort et ça c'est bon je vais viser juste
à côté
ok allez go à elle c'est pas touché
cautionner c'est ça donc nous évidemment
profiter de la vie la journée il n'y a
pas de souci d'ailleurs il ya un truc
qu'il faut savoir avec le frelon
asiatique c'est que c'est plutôt un bon
thé terre je veux dire par là qu'il
n'est pas du tout agressif
donc c'est un peu comme avec toutes les
autres bêtes en fait s'il y en a un qui
vous tourne autour rester calme et tout
se passera bien par contre si vous vous
agitez il va flipper il va se sentir
menacés et là il va vous quitter
en fait le seul vrai problème avec le
frelon asiatique c'est de tomber sur un
nid par hasard donc très attention si
vous êtes dans un coin isolé genre une
vieille ironise ou sous les toits etc et
surtout si vous tombez sur un nid
n'essayez pas de le détruire vous-même
barrez-vous et prévenez les autorités
compétentes
[Musique]
je vous mets le lien dans la description
pour visionner et si c'est trop tard au
réfectoire a alors on en a déjà parlé
dans une vidéo précédente mais je veux
remettre une petite couche premier
réflexe retirer tout ce qui entoure le
membre qui a été piqué pour éviter que
ça sert trop parce que ça risque de
gonfler ensuite vous pouvez faire un
petit saut chez le pharmacien pour voir
s'il a quelque chose à vous proposer
vous pouvez aussi mettre de la glace
pour calmer la douleur et pour faire
dégonfler
et vous pouvez aussi approché une source
de chaleur pour faire évaporer le venin
sais pas si vous vous en souvenez on en
a déjà parlé dans une vidéo dont je vous
remets le lien dans la description est
quelque part par ici je sais jamais si
vous êtes allergique vous savez sûrement
déjà coiffeur et il ya de grandes
chances que vous vous promeniez avec de
quoi vous faire une petite injection
d'adrénaline
en cas de piqûre mais vous êtes
peut-être allergiques et vous le savez
pas encore dans ces cas là si vous faite
piquer et que vous sentez des grosses
démangeaisons que vous avez l'impression
que vous commencez à gonfler notamment
au niveau
visage et de la gorge si vous avez du
mal à respirer si vous commencez un
petit peu à faire un malaise
restez calme même si on est d'accord que
dans ces cas là c'est pas facile et
appelé les secours
vous faites les appeler par quelqu'un
qui arrive à respirer normalement donc
appelé le samu au 15 ou les pompiers au
18 ou le numéro d'appel d'urgence
européen au 112 et comme d'habitude avec
ce genre de bestioles n'oubliez pas de
signaler le nid aux autorités grâce aux
liens que je vous remets dans la
description d'un but mais voilà détester
c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là profitez de l'été
prenez soin de vous et prenez soin des
autres mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]